menchov canard marie fait les billets
les blogs youtube et elle possède 31
mille abonnés instagram
mais elle est surtout l'une des rares
femmes étudiantes en génie logiciel à
l'école de technologie supérieure
on est à peu près en 2005 fait par
claude 40 à 45 éditeurs être seul dans
un milieu majoritairement masculin l'a
longtemps fait hésiter à se lancer dans
le domaine
je me demandais ce que j'allais assez
forte pour passer à travers son cas
n'est pas unique en 2017 une étude de
l'organisme technocompétences révélait
que les femmes représentent seulement 20
% des employés en technologies de
l'information
il ya des femmes qui ont réussi à percer
le marché donc c'est possible et il faut
offrir ces modèles là au jeune femme
adolescente dans cette optique une
première journée carrière destiné aux
étudiantes étaient organisées à montréal
ça m'encourage puis sinon je vois ça
comme un défi supplémentaire de
personnes dans un niveau il faut changer
ça de toute façon donc c'est seulement
encore en train d'enquêter pour faire un
changement et tu es plus supporter ce
jeu là c'est parfait je tenais pour
réseauter parce que si on est tout seul
dans nos classes comores seychelles afin
de rencontrer des femmes comme nous en
informatique
les quelques 200 participants ont pu
assister à des ateliers des conférences
et rencontrer des panélistes les flics
sont là aujourd'hui son tour au cégep et
à l'université sont des moments assez
décisif dans ce qu'on a envie de devenir
dans ce qu'on a envie d'explorer à ce
moment là donc j'ose espérer qu'on va
leur avoir donné la piqûre
l'initiative les filles et le code
chapeauté par concertation montréal en
est seulement à sa première année
d'existence
mais à court terme son objectif précis
intéresser les filles au domaine de
l'informatique dès l'âge de 12 ans ce
qui me permettrait au canada à montréal